and what was the biggest difference you
notice like when you got there given the
time period that this was I think a lot
of people who are especially younger in
technology or Silicon Valley today they
weren't around then so kind of what was
like the big thing that you saw or big
takeaways that was the difference
between somewhere like in Austin and in
Silicon Valley yeah well it was
interesting because what what seemed to
be happening was that the web was
transitioning from a network of
connected pages to now a broader
programmable platform that was going to
connect people and have stronger api's
people have been talking about web
services for a few years but now you
were seeing it writ large and you know
you didn't really know what was gonna go
but you kind of had this sense that
important things were happening and
people were sick and tired of all the
bad news the dot-com meltdown and so
this is probably late 2004 early 2005
and you go to things like the o'reilly
web to otto conference or the emerging
tech conference and jeff bezos would be
there with his laptop and you know
Stewart Butterfield and F Williams all
these people ended up playing
significant roles you could have almost
just written a check for everybody that
was in that room and done well so it was
just an exciting time and it was a lot
like my early introduction to computers
I wasn't just so much interested in
making money it was just so intriguing
and you the people who were involved
were builders and they were interested
in what's the right way to do this and
it was just a really interesting magical
time so that was kind of how I got back
in it there's just a lot more of it
happening in San Francisco than anywhere
else at the time so I concluded if I was
gonna be an investor I had to there had
to be an adequate selection of companies
to work with to really make the model
work got it and then at what point do
you decide hey you know what I think
I've learned at least enough to to go
out and start floodgate and kind of what
was the original idea there well I mean
part of it was necessity was the mother
of invention so no no venture firms
would hire me you know see you could
imagine I'm this guy from Austin Texas
I've never made an angel investment
before
enterprise software and I'm saying
there's this revolution happening and
the consumer Internet and everybody's
like yeah that's great
and you know motive had gone public it
had done really well but nobody's
Silicon Valley care right because that's
a company in Austin and so it was a the
first 18 months were kind of tough and
it was not a very not a very sort of
helpful or auspicious introduction but
um Wow but foundation capital August
Capital were nice enough to let me spend
time there and as I was there I started
to see more and more founders wanting to
raise only a million dollars and they
couldn't and what you know not only was
web to not know happening but the way
companies were building were getting
built was changing and so when I started
motive with four other people you had to
have an Oracle database on Solaris
server hosted an exodus and you know
cost you a year and five million dollars
to start and so I started to realize
five hundred thousand is the new five
million here you have open source
software offshore labor search engine
marketing broadband penetration and all
the things that cost us tons of money
and time to build from scratch was now
off-the-shelf I was like you know you're
gonna be able to you're gonna able to
get product market fit for an idea for
like a tenth of the cost that you wants
good and so hey why not why not build a
fund that's optimized right five hundred
thousand dollar checks at five million
dollar checks and that's you know there
are a few other people a similar ideas
Josh Kopelman was just starting a first
round and in those days were kind of
kindred spirits the two of us and Steve
Anderson have ended up working on
baseline and later a few other guys yeah
and then what the name floodgate where
did that come from or what was kind of
the the genesis of that yeah we were
seeking a name that connoted the idea of
an inflection so like right at the beach
so that the idea was that come to
floodgate when you feel like you have an
idea that's gonna that's going to create
massive abundance in the world
but you want to find not just investor
but a co-conspirator so you know I like
to say we want it back the top point one
percent of founders but before the world
believes and so so floodgate was kind of
like we're gonna partner with you right
up it to the point where it's time to
just open the floodgates and then it's
like we looked at people like benchmarks
of Koya client Perkins Excel Greylock as
our customers upstream and so we'd be
the first people on Omaha Beach taking
bullets with the founders and then and
then hopefully we could kind of get it
to the next level where it's a little
bit more ready for investment